Let's keep the ball rolling. September.
Again, just to finish off the point that I was just making, another thing is
like,
I don't want to see February 40 percent, March, April, May, minus 10 percent,
June, 50 percent.
Like, I would rather, I would rather have a lower yearly P and L,
but a more stable and higher average monthly P and L.
Well, you're not going to get average monthly, higher stable, but more stable.
I would rather consistently return 5 percent a month than average my return at,
let's say,
8 percent a month, but I'm having like half of the year drawdown. That's not
what I'm looking for.
I'm not looking to, you know, compound a personal account for the next 10 years
.
I'm looking to gain the system, and I'm using trading as a vehicle. Like, for
me, trading is a
vehicle. It's a vehicle to a bigger means, right? Like, I want to build, my
intention is to build
my own trading floors, my own hedge fund. This is just a stepping star. I don't
want to be
trading my own capital five years from now. I want to have people like you
trading capital
with me. That's my goal. When I'm going to trade any of that,
right? Let me focus with bearish. It's Monday the 4th of September. That was L
FP, right?
Yes. Okay, now we're 4th of September.
Let's go. Let's get some shorts.
New York, New York, baby. Give me some. Give me some shorts.
Nice. That makes things a lot easier.
Yep.
That's shorts.
Again, I could probably get away with putting my stops here or here.
Maybe even London High, right?
But it's not something I'm testing right now. That's something that I'll maybe
test out later
day in time, for example, because I don't know that I'm just assuming. Initial
balance,
let's go. We don't have any news already checked. Oh, wait. No.
And where could I have about my stop loss? That was my thesis.
All right. It makes for such a better risk reward. Risk reward goes from,
if I have my stop loss where I wanted it, it's a one to eight, but what I'm
taking one to five.
Okay, London session, boom, boom. What was the return on that? 6.8%.
It didn't partial at five bar, but it's one and 15 candle.
Again, I reckon I could have had my stops.
No, it wasn't. It wasn't 6.8. I think it was one to five. They're really nice.
I haven't had many of them. New York, sleep London.
I think this is also an A+ setup. No, it's not.
The empty price legs, they work a lot. Again, I used to make the mistake all
the time of like
forcing the idea that price had to retrace back into this area for me to be
able to short,
but so many times you just see that price just moves from nowhere, because
there's already too
much volume. But the direction's already been decided. Do you want to wait for
perfect
conditions to come back into here? Like, I'm going to miss so many
opportunities. And I did.
I'm actually seeing these empty legs that work and they work a treat because it
's liquidity-based.
The big thing is it's not just pro-trend area of interest. Now it's like it's
liquidity-based.
That's what really moves the market. And people will say, and even some of the
institutional traders that I'm learning from at the moment, institutional
traders, should I say,
he's not with all the old ICT liquidity sweeps and all that sort of stuff. But
the reality is,
it's like it works. So, yeah. I think maturing as a trader has kind of just
been a little bit
neutral. Because I see it. Like, I see the old old kind of school,
institutional hedge fund
background, Wall Street background type traders. And they're like, "Ah, there's
ICT stuff, blah, blah,
it's so bad." And then you've got these new school traders that's like, I was
like that at the
beginning. Full transparency. Like, "Ah, ICT is everything. The banks, the
algorithm, like,
all this BS." And it's like, the truth is always somewhere in the middle.
That's what I found to be so true in life. The truth is always somewhere in the
middle.
It's not black and white. It's grey.
Premium discount. Hard to check. Cool.
Now we are looking at New York session, but I don't think that we're actually
going to get
anything here. There's maybe a little pullback here. Who knows, too. But I was
still considered
as just purely discretion. Probably not going to get any faster back of this,
either.
What's the structure flow like? See, this is where you have to look at
structure because
we're inside of these big legs. But if price is outside of the legs, you don't
even have to
think about it. For example, like here. I don't have to think about the
structure here because
it's outside the leg. But the moment that you get these big legs and then price
ends up back
inside of them, you now have to start thinking about it. I can start here. I
wish you if bullish
here. I wish you if bearish down here. Yeah, so we are pretty much.
We are bearish from essentially the swing highs.
But we can do internal.
Wednesday the 6th at 2am. There's no news, but that looks like a new scandal to
me.
Ah, that's so cool. I don't know you could do that. I can change wherever I'm z
ooming in or
wherever I'm going across just by clicking shift.
And then, like really and truly, I'm just going to use this m5 water block.
Which is the m15 on the block. We know that it doesn't go to the target, but
that doesn't
matter. I still need to understand what's my estimated average. What's my
target risk, target reward.
And I'm pretty sure this just literally tagged straight in and goes.
Which is an interesting one. It tags in there. It needs to break that low.
Which it fails to do. And then stops. Cool.
I don't know where I got this preconceived notion that it has to break the lows
.
I think I just made it up at some point.
One thing I will say is that this system is completely unique in the sense that
the system is derived of the three kinds of pullback principle.
Unless there are other traders out there, of course, it's possible that I've
found my ideas and copied me and gone out their way to build systems and stuff
based off of
the very kind of world, which is obviously understandable. I invented that
myself completely.
This is entirely predicated off of that as the forefront of the principle.
So this isn't something that every trader out there understands.
And this is a whole other notion as well. I should laugh at people that say SMC
traps and liquidity traps and smart money traps and stuff. People don't realize
,
people don't realize. And I'm friends with some of them. I understand what they
're doing.
It's just marketing play. But if you've come across the notion of SMC traps,
for example, maybe you know how I'm talking about, it's laughable because this
preconceived notion,
the number one, if you look at the trades, they don't even make any sense.
I don't know what SMC traders are trading those, but they're not profitable.
The second thing is just finding any water blocking calling a liquidity trap is
laughable.
The second thing is that for something to be a liquidity trap, it has to be
an order that is visible in the order book. Now, 99% plus of these SMC type
traders,
and I consider myself as an SMC trader, 99% of SMC traders are trading on demo
accounts.
Your prop firm CFD account is a demo account. If you have a personal account
and you trade
CFDs, meaning you trade your old dollar on a brokerage account, your orders
aren't going to
the live market. They are going to the be book, so your orders aren't even
appearing on the order
book. Unless you're trading your futures and you're trading your futures on an
actual broker,
or you're confirmed to be in the a book on a prop firm, your orders aren't
going to the market.
And so we have a million SMC traders maybe taking the exact same trade.
And all of that liquidity doesn't exist. It's fogacy. It doesn't exist. It's
not in the order book.
So this idea that that person's liquidity is at that level, it's just bullshit.
Excuse my French,
but it's laughable. And that said that in of itself tells you a lot about the
traders saying it.
Like, again, I understand it's just marketing thing, but if someone's saying, "
Oh, these SMC
traps," or these traps, or that trap, all these SMC traders are getting in
there and they're,
yeah, you really think the markets go in there because of all those SMC traders
whose
liquidity doesn't even go to the live market, because none of them are trading
personal accounts.
They're all trading prop firms, or they're all trading demos. Even your live
prop firm is a demo.
So, and okay, let's say you have a handful of traders, 100 traders with $100,
000 each in their
own live personal funds accounts, which is extremely rare and they're
profitable. Number one, they're
not taking those trades. Number two, they are making up a fraction. Let's say
they're risking 1%.
So, there's $10,000 worth of buy stops or sell stops in that level.
Wow, the market really cares about, you know, whatever it is, God knows, like,
100 lots.
Whoa, it's laughable. Excuse my rants. Frankfurt, sweep, reversal, point of
interest.
Empty log.
Huh, how kind. Um,
don't really know how this works. I mean, we don't break,
so this isn't a low. I also forgot that.
That is discretion.
I don't really know how to go about this. We can even go for a second try or
wait for some more
confirmation. Why do I feel like that's H-COP? Because H-COP always runs 50
minutes before,
but it's not, apparently. Well, now we have some nice buy side liquidity.
We're still looking for shorts.
I assume at 10. I think we could trade this if it breaks this low.
Oh, my God. What am I thinking?
ISM is at 10. Didn't even think about it. Thank God for that.
Obviously, we're looking for shorts.
I don't get them.
We are looking for shorts again.
Yeah, this is really clean price action, by the way. Like really clean.
Yeah, honestly, probably they're just the M5 holder block because I know that
there's a decent
size wish to reward all this buy to sell. Again, with my start, so I can get
away with my stop there.
But I tend to feel never need to put it higher.
And no, I can technically put it here.
But that's not just be stupid because there will be some times where price will
come in
here and I'll get tagged out and it'll be just stupid. And I'll be annoyed that
I did it.
That's not something that I'm doing right now. It's something that I will later
develop. It's NFP.
Oh, no. We had an NFP on the first.
Okay.
Well, I've already said the stop bus now.
Like that becomes mitigated.
Don't see why I can't just move my stops to a given.
Like sure, it's unmet again in the 30 minute, but I'm not trading in the 30
minute.
It tags me out a break even. It tags me out a break even.
This is one of those where it tags that fast and runs away that you might get
tagged back
at a break even. And then suffer the consequences. But hey,
the age of long.
Hmm. That's fine.
Break even.
Oh well. Better stack up small wins.
Do we shift bullish? Yeah. Okay.
We just shift bearish. No.
But I'm just naturally up on us, right?
Yeah.
The little sweep of London low would be great and a little reversal.
So I'm talking about that right there is the type of trade that I like to see.
And it's a guaranteed reversal.
Now we find our entry and worried that this area may get us getting the way of
us getting
into this position to be totally honest with you. Let's see, restore award.
I'm not going to play around with my stop loss on this position.
One to turn. Let's see. I think that I could potentially have my entry a little
bit higher,
but it doesn't matter. And we're out.
But we may be back in real quick.
Technical re-entry.
Maybe back to back losses here, but it's a 12.
30w.
Um, where do I want to enter?
This inverter I got here, this inverter I got here.
Maybe just this five minute cell to buy. This here.
Okay.
And that's two in a row.
Why does everything seem so messy?
It's annoying, really annoying press action.
That hurts.
I liked that setup from day one from the moment I seen it as well.
They're both the same setup.
Point of interest. I'm going to go a strong point of interest here.
Because it is a structural flow.
We'll go a character and trend is
confirm reversal. Yes. No.
Okay. So.
It's an unlucky one. Today is the thirteenth.
Wednesday, the thirteenth.
Inflation rates.
So it's still looking at lungs here.
Now a huge fan of this press action.
I think it is a little bit choppy at this point.
It's not nice when it's just moving in these nice ebbs and flows.
This is a little bit more choppy.
But yeah, let's see.
Let me check the M1 structure because this was pretty volatile.
So this would have to go down as internal.
I'm. Yes. And.
So two Asia highs appear.
It's a lot of liquidity.
Oh, sugar. This is actually a buy stop.
So I wouldn't have been a stop plus.
Okay.
I'll be able to limit.
It's really like. It's a weak point of interest.
These weak point of interest don't do very well.
No, no, I it's still.
What is it doing?
Why am I in $5 profit?
Do not say stuff loss. I didn't say stuff loss.
Okay, hold on, hold on, hold on.
0.9 lots. Okay, hold on a second.
Try again.
Why is this stuff like that?
Okay, let's remove it all.
Let's try again.
It's pretty much.
There you go.
We take another trade, so.
That's white.
Oh, nice invite.
How about you go?
Probably going to put my stuff there,
but I'm not going to try and.
Haggle my way through the trades.
We don't have any news.
Ah, I don't like the rest of the world on that.
Okay, let's bring it down.
Should see I'm 15 one book.
Cool.
See tag and.
Stops.
Okay, that's two stops.
One time we tagged in.
Cool.
And this one.
So.
Two to three and.
A four to five.
This is the four to five.
I'm not a huge fan of this price action.
I'm not a huge fan of this price.
I'm a huge fan of this price action.
So we're holding a little bit of drawdown.
We are profitable for September, but we are definitely not having a great win
rate.
And we are holding drawdown.
Damn it.
Not a fan of these subs.
I'm a huge fan of this price action.
I'm a very good management.
This is a...
I don't even know where my structure leg is.
I think it's here.
I'm a huge fan of this price action.
Mm-hmm.
That's tradable.
No other news.
I don't have to probably go internal.
No entry.
We are still bearish.
Twenty-thiff.
I can't trade that.
Nope.
We're not going to go trade.
Let's change the character.
Nope.
This is really scruffy price action.
I'm a huge fan of this price action.
This is hard price action.
I just don't have the restore award.
I can't trade that, but even that's not restore award.
Twenty-seventh.
Wait, twenty-seventh.
Don't have any news.
That's cheeky.
You can try it.
Honestly, not a huge fan of that setup.
I like to get to break even.
I can reduce my risk here.
I don't like this at all.
It's a little bit better.
Fair enough.
Not a huge fan of the price action, but it follows the rules to perfection.
Didn't mean to do that.
Did I miss a trade?
We're bearish.
It's not reversal.
Still bearish, twenty-eighth.
We have GDP growth rate and inflation.
That's GDP growth rate.
We could trade that.
Oh, my God.
Eighteen pip stop.
No, not a chance.
Somewhat fortunate, but like eighteen pip stop loss and I wanted to restore
awards.
Like I would have to expect price to go running into uncharted territory like
crazy.
Probably not going to get a trade.
Friday the 29th is probably going to be the last trade of the month.
And there we become bullish.
And yeah.
Also probably not going to trade London, New York, sorry.
Have to sweep Asia.
And now it comes to second October.
So that's September.
Very bad win rate.
Things like a twenty-five percent win rate for that month.
I'm guessing twenty-five percent.
Probably because I don't have any loss reduction.
Yeah.
The average win to lose in ratio is a lot lower.
It's not a great zealous score at all.
We have a few. That's why.
Seven losers and pretty much all seven losers are full capacity losses.
And the winners are not full capacity winners.
That's why it's not great.
But it's a six percent month.
Hmm.
Actually ends up not a bad month at all.
But not a great stats.
And a poor zealous score.
A poor profit factor.
Yeah, we go on this.
Well, everything was going great and then six losses in a row.
That's why the score is so terrible.
But I mean, six percent is not bad.
Twenty-seven percent win rate.
Win rates creeping up.
The drawdown is not great.
Win percentage not great.
But consistency, average winter loss, recovery factor at all on point.
It has forty-six percent in February, March, April, May, June, July, August,
September, eight months.
Forty-six percent in eight months.
Yeah, so about five point seven percent average monthly returns, which is still
very decent.